we begin with the big shake-up at CVS
less than two months after the
investigation into allegations of
misconduct by CEO Leslie Moonves it's
official he's out his wife Julie Chen
was not on the talk today but her
husband's departure was topic number one
as you will know Dooley's husband is in
the news it's very embarrassing and
upsetting to have to talk about our
husband but we do we feel it's right
it's not being convicted of any crime
but obviously the man has a problem why
is it that when men get power it goes to
their testicles I do not know why but
it's true the talk co-host Julie Chen
who has been married to Leslie Moonves
for nearly 14 years released a statement
just as the show was going live for it
season 9 premiere saying quote I am
taking a few days off from the talk to
be with my family I will be back soon
Julie Chen and I know is very strong a
resilient woman but I think this is a
blessing from God to be unburdened from
secrets and Unchained from lies Chen
says she will resume her big brother
hosting duties Thursday night with the
ladies fuelled speculation about the
future of the talk when a new regime
comes into a company we all know they
sweep clean the Exeter Leslie Moonves
came shortly after a follow up New
Yorker report was published yesterday
investigative journalist Ronan Farrow
spoke to six more women who claimed they
were sexually harassed by Moonves
bringing the total number of accusers to
12 the follow-up story on Sunday
contained disturbing accounts of forced
physical contact
Moonves announced he was leaving in a
statement that read in part quote untrue
allegations from decades ago are now
being made against me that are not
consistent with Who I am
Moonves has made more than 650 million
dollars as CBS CEO since 2006 this is an
earthquake in Hollywood and in New York
Harvey Weinstein almost looks like a
small fry compared to Les Moonves
we're on top and we intend to stay there
he had an enormous amount of influence
and power and frankly at a pretty
stellar reputation until Ronin Pharaohs
reporting started to come out details of
moonves's severance package are being
worked out right now we don't know if
he's gonna make a hundred twenty million
dollars in the way out the door or zero
or some amount in between as part of his
severance though CBS is donating 20
million to organizations that support
equality for women in the workplace so
what is next Joe Aiello is the acting
CEO now he's been Moonves his number two
for a long time he's gonna meet with his
staff for the first time on Wednesday an
email today to CBS employees I anello
promised continuity and stability well
we also want to point out that et is
produced and distributed by CBS
Television Distribution
you